will star trek iv the new star trek jj
abrams movie be loosely based on the
undiscovered country
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so as we know the new star trek movie
has been announced we're going to see
another star trek movie from the jj
abrams kelvin timeline
maneuvering thrusters mr summer
thrusters on standby
take us out
i think that the jj abrams films are
very entertaining i think they're
beautifully made i think they're good
action movies i think they're quite
funny in places
but they're not star trek
they're not even really very good sci-fi
in places because you know the science
fiction the science part is still quite
important
go back and look at the videos though
where i've talked about that in detail
but what about this idea that this movie
is going to be based loosely on the
undiscovered country now this has come
to me from sources that have worked on
the preliminary artwork for the movie
they haven't seen the script but they
have seen some of the concept art and
things they've actually worked on it and
so they have seen a general gist of
where they think the story is going
also this person that i have spoken to
has actually worked on previous movies
and he actually told me that the idea
always has been with these films except
the first one
to loosely base
these jt abrams movies on other star
trek films now
when he told me that i went huh
um but obviously into darkness is very
clearly a little bit of a remake of the
wrath of khan it was
loosely inspired by it they brought a
couple of characters back they took
certain elements of the story but then
they created a new movie based around
those
few little threads
now
star trek beyond according to this
source was loosely also based on a
couple of star trek movies now then i
really went huh
but
he basically said they took elements
from um the search for spock
particularly in the way the enterprise
was destroyed they that was supposed to
be reminiscent from elements of the
search of spock they also though took
elements of the final frontier and
merged those or used those as starting
points when they wrote the story
now
i i think they took those few ideas and
then went
off in completely different directions
but kind of you can see that with into
darkness as well like to be fair that
they took a nugget from the original
movie and just went and used his
inspiration and then just created a
whole new film
in range
not yet sir come on come on you should
fly apart fire
according to my source j.j abrams wanted
to do this from the beginning he said he
wanted to take elements from the star
trek movie the star trek franchises
taking elements from the original canon
but then using that to inspire them to
create something completely new
so that it would feel like star trek but
not be a remake not be a reboot it would
be something still new
now
he's definitely done that i'm not going
to argue with it but why would they then
not make the voyage home well my source
says just because picard just did that
series 2 of picard
very much felt like in elements the
voyage home yes we didn't have any
whales jumping around but you could
argue we had the borg and that whole bit
and then that was sort of a bit
reminiscent of that idea the ball coming
through and there being this enemy this
rift if you do like the content by the
way guys please consider hitting the
subscribe button consider sharing the
video wherever the hell you like him
hitting that like don't hit the down
that doesn't help anybody
also
consider becoming a fully fled side
track and hit the join button all these
little things they really helped me to
keep the channel going in and then those
few little pennies that basically means
the wife will let me keep doing it
again if you're a regular sidetracker
you might know the undiscovered country
is my favorite star trek movie from the
original cast it's my favorite star trek
movie because my mom watches these
videos so sorry i skyped off school and
went and swatched at the cinema um i
watched it on my own in the cinema on a
on a weekday afternoon
it was the first star trek movie i ever
got to see at the cinema
and it made an impact on me because of
that i also i just love the starting
sequence
of praxis exploding and
um
the end is a bit weak but
for me it's my favorite original cast
star trek movie
i would love them to bring elements of
that back
but also there are reasons
on a more political worldwide scale and
why actually this movie might have
relevance at the moment
that film was
not very subtly about the cold war and
the collapse of the cold war and the
collapse of the berlin wall that the
collapse of the soviet union the
klingons in this respect are the soviet
union they're in collapse their economy
has been completely destroyed and
they're like a bit of a animal backed
into a corner they're most at risk they
were looking at the federation and
looking at peace
but elements within the klingon empire
didn't want that elements within the
federation didn't want that
oh now be honest captain
warrior to warrior
you do prefer it this way don't you as
it was meant to be
no peace in our time
in the last few years
the cold war has sort of
got warm again we do not have a good
relationship with our friends comrades
in the east
obviously there's the conflict in the
ukraine which i think could again become
quite a
big part of this new movie or used as
again as a metaphor for this new movie i
think if this movie is done right and it
is done in the way that i imagine it it
could become relevant to the current
situation between east and west matt
shakman is going to be directing this
movie and he is just coming off back of
the success of marvel's one division a
series that has been generally applauded
for its style
even though i found the first couple of
episodes quite boring it was cleverly
done and the director was a big part of
that
the script has been rewritten a few
times because this movie was actually
supposedly supposed to be made a few
years ago but
following the back of beyond not doing
very well at all it got shelved but now
paramount plus are really pushing for
this again and the director actually
says all the evidence suggests people
desperately want to see it and to be
fair it's had a lot of clicks on since
then the green lighting was accidentally
released and even before the actors knew
that the film was coming back we all did
i love that it doesn't happen very often
but actually talking to actors i have
been told that actually these things do
happen quite a lot that movies are
released and they actually don't know
that that it's about to be happened but
then they just release it to the general
public and the publicist they don't
bother actually telling actors first and
like they might be busy that day but you
know they just don't do that um so yeah
this is something that um i am excited
about
it is a shame that um one or two actors
won't be returning um the actor that
played check off was one of my favorites
and it's really sad that he won't be
returning um but it looks like all the
other actors will we are getting the
whole cast back together so hey
good films not star trek but i'm still
excited to see it get in the comments
please guys and tell me what you think
is this a project you are looking
forward to
they are always beautifully made so at
very least we've got that right
tell me what you think also if you are
new to the channel please like subscribe
hit the bell notification it really
helps us out thumbs up thumbs down helps
nobody also if you like the content that
i make for you consider becoming a fully
fledged site tracker it really helps us
out hit the join button as always please
stay safe i'll see you next time
[Music]
you